StuH Woo's nothing but stuff okay I'm
gonna let you know this usually I wear
but Star Wars curtain cape that I had as
a childhood I was the Star Wars movies
but I'm in it I'll save that for the
spoiler review for now gonna wear the
usual get up you know bring a little
professionalism to this world of madness
so let's talk one
[Music]
one a Star Wars story so rogue - Star
Wars story is a movie that fills in the
gap between Revenge of the Sith and Star
Wars a new hope kind of it's actually a
little closer it really is the story of
that opening crawl of the original Star
Wars yeah that's the story and that you
have jyn erso jyn erso gets picked up by
the rebellion they're like yeah we need
your help was on the wrong story short
at that point that find out there is a
super death weapon that's supposed to
eradicate planets there's gonna be an
imminent weapons tests and now they've
got to take the plans of did you know
you know or there's a lot full of about
this movie I'm not gonna lie to you
first of all jyn erso Generoso was great
Felicity Jones plays jyn erso very well
just a welcome addition to the entire
Star Wars cast as a whole you know you
saw that line from the trailer where she
was like I rebelled you're like but is
she gonna be good
don't worry that lines not even I don't
remember the line in the movie at all
what is the crappiest line in the
trailer isn't actually in the movie and
that's a good thing also the standouts
of the rogue one cast rk2 the droid yeah
named after a mountain he was awesome
dude was hysterical the audience was
roaring and everything he said I loved
everything his a sarcastic dick and
Donnie yen's character Donnie Yen was
rad Donnie yen's character lays some
depth to the force and the Jedi and who
can and cannot use the force in some way
shape or form I said it was great I love
it when characters add complexity to
already existing lore he did that for
the forest take the fact that this movie
is jumping into already-existing Laura
at that point is they all right what's
it gonna do with the Lord it's like the
rebellion for example the rebellion in
here they're not squeaky clean it's not
like ooh Empire bad guys rebellion good
guys it is you know it is let me
rephrase if not elaborate what I mean is
that there are some parts with rebellion
guys just kind of make a call or to
where you're like that was kind of dick
because it's an ugly world with an ugly
empire and you're in an ugly Civil War
it's gonna be ugly and sometimes the
good guys gonna have to make calls that
ride the line right there morally
ambiguous moments I thought that was
really cool it just made the rebellion
not so squeaky clean I also loved critic
he's great I mean if you're signing on
to this movie for Darth Vader because
you saw Darth Vader in the trailer don't
fader is sparingly in this movie if in
fact I would say if Vader was not in
this movie at all the movie would be no
different it doesn't do much that's not
a negative to the movie I'm just saying
you saw Vader in the trailer I want you
to keep your expectation
didn't check on that but chronic was
great it was a good antagonist coming
after these guys he has a job to do he
needs to get this battle station under
control and needs to get things working
solid Imperial douche never does this
movie have flaws yes it does it being a
review gonna name him the lead up in
this film the build-up it's not always
smooth it's a bit choppy you're being
introduced to these characters that
character here character here character
here that's a lot of characters that you
don't really have the backstories for
but this movies like ad here they are
because you gotta get going not always a
smoothest thing ever and Forest Whitaker
plays Sagar ara
I feel like Sagar eras in this movie for
no other reason other than the fact that
they wanted a character from the Clone
Wars animation now still alive to show
you hey it all ties together really the
flaws in the film are in that first hour
of build up the rest of the movie is
really good if not great it's
entertaining it's action-packed it has a
great sky about it like the battles the
fights the skirmishes in rogue one are
some of the best and Star Wars yet it's
super intense at a point they're like
alright we're doing the thing to get the
thing trying to keep it kind of vague
for people who might not know what I'm
talking about I was on the edge of my
seat just white-knuckling it like Oh
importantly what this film did is it
move Star Wars into another kind of box
like every Star Wars movie you look at
you watch and it feels like a Star Wars
movie this one does still feel like a
Star Wars movie and since it takes place
in the Star Wars universe but it made it
a bit more down in the mud a bit more
gritty bit more for adults example you
look at the stormtrooper armor in the
force awakens it's always like very
clean the whites are very white throw
glowing you see the stormtrooper armor
it's all like dingy dirty like it's been
through or the guys just lounging like I
just I just want to punch out as I'm
pretty sure my here's my shift over
Kevin Smith actually said I bet this is
I think this is what he meant by it he
said something like rogue one is on the
level of Empire Strikes Back or
something like that I'm paraphrasing for
sure but that's what he tweeted but he's
right in the sense in perspective that I
have reached on this when Empire Strikes
Back came out it was like one of those I
okay it's good but as time goes on and
you think about Empire Strikes Back and
the layers in Empire Strikes Back Empire
Strikes Back
exponentially gets better if you're like
that's rogue one when I walked out of
this movie I was going to give it us
certainly worth watching I'm buying on
blu-ray it was great but as I started
thinking about it the more I really
liked it and the more the flaws in the
beginning of the film started to subside
and there's a scene oh yeah better shut
up or is that
I just want to talk about it and I will
say rogue one a Star Wars story is
awesome tacular I will say it like this
rogue one a Star Wars story is like the
female orgasm so little slow to start
takes a bit to get going once it does
it's a solid climb to a really powerful
climax it has some problems with
character and pacing in the first act
for sure but in the end it all comes
together I mean really comes together
when you're out of that move you're like
I want to pop in a new hope right now
and watch that right guys so rogue one a
Star Wars story have you seen it what
did you think about it the reviews a
little early are you looking forward to
seeing it what do you hope when you see
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]